yesterday we talked a little bit
about how Joe Biden's visit to Ukraine
on President's Day can you imagine has
been used to say well he really should
have been at the border or he really
should really should have been in East
Palestine I was told very politely by
people I was mispronouncing it yesterday
this is the problem when I only read
news as opposed to watch it I don't know
that it's pronounced Palestine instead
of Palestine okay the argument that some
of these right-wingers were making was
oh it was the wrong day to go to Ukraine
instead of the Border or to Ohio uh the
brains of a lot of these folks continue
to break endlessly uh don Jr made the
argument
that it was particularly bad that Biden
went to Ukraine on President's Day
because Russia is to blame for the train
derailments I mean it's it's all making
very little sense hey we have
derailments after train derailment with
environmental disasters no one asking if
it's maybe the Russians retaliating
after the article came out about us
possibly attacking the Nordstrom 2
pipeline okay that article has been
widely debunked and it's based on almost
nothing the the article has been
ridiculed widely and has been widely
debunked we actually know with almost
total certainty what happened with the
train derailment there are hot box
detectors which are recommended to be
placed every 20 or 25 miles to determine
is something getting too hot on the
train a bearing or other things
there is video footage that suggests
that 20 miles out of East Palestine
there was already a fire on the train
there was no such detector there to
notify the train crew as a result
because it is not a requirement to have
those hot box detectors
we ended up with what we ended up with
and Don Jr is talking about Russia you
know the the trumps love to say why does
everybody talk about Russia he's talking
about Russia when it makes no sense to
be talking about Russia and it's all
because their brains are broken also
important to mention
over time train derailments per person
per mile traveled have continued to
decline in the United States that
they're not actually up there are still
too many train derailments and they are
unfortunately regular thing if you count
train and Subway and all these different
things
but derailments have actually declined
so that's Don Jr Ben Shapiro on the
other hand suggests with no evidence
that the air raid sirens in the
background of Biden's visit to Ukraine
were
um stage managed they were staged for
Biden's visit
a clip came out of Joe Biden walking
through Kiev with Vladimir zielinski and
the air raid sirens go off
uh It's Curious it's weird they don't
even break nobody even nobody even for a
second in the Press pool like looks
around like normally when the air raid
sirens go off and I've been in countries
when air raid sirens have gone off right
I mean like I was in Jerusalem last year
the era teens didn't actually go off in
Jerusalem but they you were checking
your phone consistently for like where
are the rocket attacks falling isn't
that the best he goes I've been in
countries where Air Raid Sirens are
going off like for example I was in
Jerusalem actually the air raid sirens
weren't going off but I was keeping a
really close eye on my phone uh
that's it's ridiculous
people tend to have a tendency when a
giant noise goes off that says you
should get to shelter people tend to at
least look in the air in this clip
nobody looks in the air there's a reason
for that as we'll explain in just a
moment here was Joe Biden with Vladimir
zielinski yesterday walking through cave
[Music]
thank you
it well there's only a couple of
problems with that clip one again nobody
looks in the air while the air raid
sirens are going off the second is that
a CNN reporter then went on the air and
he's like oh yeah by the way um we
haven't heard an Irish ironing key but
for like five weeks
literally the only moment I've heard
narrated siren for the last five weeks
has been when Joe Biden walked outside
with Vladimir zielinski which sort of
suggests that what they really wanted
was a photo op a big Brave Joe Biden
dark aviator glasses dark Brandon
walking around keep with the air raid
sirens going off like Winston Churchill
and the rubble of London or something
all right so there's Ben Shapiro's
incisive commentary the air raid sirens
were certainly staged and then here's
Fox news reporter deporter reporter
Peter Ducey who didn't like the tone I
guess of the Biden speech and
um Okay let's listen President Biden
disagrees with that and we expect him to
expand on that theme later on today uh
at this speech which should start in a
few minutes and it's not the solemn set
of remarks that we were kind of told to
expect based on the existential threats
that he sees it has almost a campaign
rally feel like uh like if they were
having a campaign rally for democracy
virus wow how terrible that would be
let's rally for democracy which is in
Peril and in danger the world over
um so uh
this wasn't it wasn't a sad enough event
for Peter Ducey the atmosphere was like
too rally-like in favor of democracy
which seems by the way like a pretty
worthy cause to me so they don't even
know what sorts of criticisms to make at
this point in time because the truth is
Biden looked Strong by going to Ukraine
so they go well President's Day was the
wrong day to go or he should have been
at the derailment or he should have been
at the border or the atmosphere should
have been sadder or the air raid sirens
were staged or Russia did the the
derailment or whatever the case may be
for which it's conspiracies and whining
ultimately what we are getting from the
right at this point in time their brains
are cracking like an egg and breaking uh
and I don't expect this to change at all
anytime soon meanwhile Trump's spending
time on Truth social posting about Ron
DeSantis and almost nobody's paying
attention so you can understand why
they're upset and why they're scrambling
and why they are so triggered later in
the program we will look at sort of more
these are slightly more cartoonish
reactions we're going to look at kind of
the the scarier reactions from some on
the right to the news of the last 72
hours stay with us remember we can
really use your help getting to 2
million YouTube subscribers go to
youtube.com the davidpackman show slam
that subscribe button we appreciate it